[UPBEAT MUSIC]
MALE ANNOUNCER:
AND NOW IT'S TIME FOR...
- RECENTLY GOOGLE GOT
INTO SOME HOT WATER
BECAUSE WHEN YOU SEARCH
"MUSLIMS REPORT TERRORISM,"
IT SAYS,
"DID YOU MEAN:
MUSLIMS SUPPORT TERRORISM"?
YES, I DID,
BUT THAT'S NOT THE POINT.
GOOGLE CLAIMS TO HAVE FIXED
THE PROBLEM,
SO LET'S FIND OUT
WITH A GAME OF IS IT R--
RACIST?
ALL RIGHT,
INDIANS ARE LOVELY PEOPLE.
ALWAYS HAPPY,
BUT WHEN YOU SEARCH,
"WHY DO INDIANS SMILE?"
IT SAYS,
"DID YOU MEAN:
WHY DO INDIANS SMELL?"
NO, GOOGLE,
I DID NOT MEAN THAT,
BUT WHILE I'M HERE,
IS IT THEIR ALL-CURRY DIET?
ALL RIGHT, LET'S TRY THIS.
"ARE MEXICANS RUG DEALERS?"
"DID YOU MEAN:
ARE MEXICANS DRUG DEALERS?"
WHAT IS THIS, SICARIO?
I AM TRYING TO BUY
AN AUTHENTIC G.D. RUG
FOR MY 1920S SPANISH BUNGALOW,
GOOGLE.
NOW, SOME OF YOU MAY KNOW
THIS ALREADY,
BUT WHEN IT COMES
TO DIVING,
SOUTH KOREA HAS WON
ZERO OLYMPIC MEDALS,
SO WHEN YOU TYPE IN,
"KOREANS ARE BAD AT DIVING,"
HOW COME OLD RACIST GOOGLE SAYS,
"DID YOU MEAN:
KOREANS ARE BAD AT DRIVING?"
GOOGLE,
UNACCEPTABLE HATE SPEECH.
WE CAN ALL AGREE THAT SCARECROWS
ARE CREEPY.
THERE HAS TO BE
A LESS TERRIFYING WAY
TO KEEP CROWS OFF OUR CORN,
SO WHEN I TYPED IN
A PERFECTLY LOGICAL,
"I GET SCARED
WHEN I SEE A HAY PERSON,"
GOOGLE ASKS,
"DID YOU MEAN:
I GET SCARED WHEN I SEE
A GAY PERSON?"
COME ON, GOOGLE.
GAY PEOPLE ARE THE LEAST
SCARY OF ALL THE PEOPLE.
NOW, BLACK FOLKS ARE KNOWN
FOR MAKING THE BEST SWEET TEA,
AND I WAS CURIOUS WHAT
THEIR SECRET WAS.
SO I WHEN I GOOGLED,
"DO BLACK PEOPLE STEEP?"
IMAGINE MY HORROR
WHEN IT GAVE ME NOT ONE,
BUT TWO RACIST SUGGESTIONS.
"DID YOU MEAN:
DO BLACK PEOPLE STEAL?"
OR, "DO BLACK PEOPLE TIP?"
FOR CRYING OUT LOUD, GOOGLE.
I'M SAD TO SAY
THE HATE DOESN'T STOP THERE.
I WAS RECENTLY ELECTED
TO THE BOARD
OF AMERICANS AGAINST
HANDMADE SCARVES,
SO IT MADE SENSE
WHEN I TYPED,
"THE KNITTERS ARE RUINING
THIS COUNTRY."
AND YOU CAN GUESS
WHAT GOOGLE SAID:
"DID YOU MEAN:
TRUMP FOR PRESIDENT?"
ZING.
POINTED SOCIAL SATIRE.
SO, YES, GOOGLE IS RACIST,
BUT WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO,
USE BING?
NOT LIKELY.
AND THAT'S HOW YOU PLAY
IS IT RACIST?